bonjour razzy hammadi merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france alors vous êtes
bloqués depuis quelques jours sur l'île
de bali en indonésie
vous avez eu des nouvelles du consulat
français
quels sont justement ces nouvelles et
est ce que vous vous sentez accompagnés
par les autorités françaises écoutez on
sent bien que l'ambassade qu'elle peut
c'est à dire que je crois que le nombre
de français ici en indonésie est assez
important puisqu'on se retrouve en
discute à travers les réseaux sociaux on
arrive à être en contact on les change
nombreuses informations liées aux
annulations de vols report l'ambassade à
ce message ce message assez simple qui
est de dire essayer par tous les moyens
possibles de rentrer au plus tôt
deuxième élément du message
sachez que nous travaillons à un
rapatriement dans le cadre de
discussions avec le gouvernement
indonésien
maintenant pour beaucoup d'entre nous
nous arrivons un petit peu au bout du
bout parce que les ambassades ne sont
certes pas des compagnies ou des agences
de voyages mais nous sommes beaucoup
dans cette situation finalement chacun
des vols prix entraînant des dépenses
importantes pour beaucoup d'entre eux
lim cela peut représenter de grosses
sommes peuvent se retrouver annulé alors
pourquoi ils se retrouvent à bulles est
souvent pourquoi parce que justement les
correspondances sont dépendantes des
situations particulières dédié justement
français pour vous donner un exemple
très concret singapour interdite y
compris le transit pour les français qui
ont quitté la france depuis moins de 14
jours donc pour tous ceux qui sont dans
une situation dite de voyages
professionnels comme moi et qui suis
arrivé ici pour moins d'une semaine le
retour par singapour est aujourd'hui
maintenant par de nombreux autres pays
devient très difficile sachant qu'une
fois qu'on a atteint cette fameuse durée
de 14 jours
quelquefois au delà même du transit il
devient possible pour des français de
repasser par d'autres pays transit ou
pas vous vouliez un l'ambassade vous
vous conseille de prendre vos
dispositions de prendre vous même vos
vos billets
existe-t-il assez de vol et est ce que
les billets ne sont pas pris d'assaut
directement non très clairement les vols
il va par là je viens d'apprendre
qu'aucune réservation sur air france klm
n'est possible avant le mois de mai pour
ce qui me concerne j'ai eu une chance
inouïe mais on va voir si celle ci
perdure puisque j'ai réussi à avoir un
vol jeudi
est-ce qu'il sera maintenu ou pas ou est
ce qu'il connaîtra le même sort que mes
trois réservation précédente
d'autant que voilà je souhaite retrouver
ma femme ma psy et puis quand bien même
professionnellement avec mon agence
mustang cities les choses arrivent à
s'organiser professionnellement assez
bien il n'en demeure pas moins que l'on
préfère être sous la pluie avec les
siens que seul sous le soleil
et quelles sont les nouvelles des
autorités indonésiennes est-ce que vous
avez des nouvelles est ce qu'on vous
donne des directives alors les premières
directives sont arrivés hier soir avec
des sms envoyés sur l'ensemble des puces
électroniques et des puces de téléphone
indonésienne restez chez vous ne sortez
pas pas de rassemblement la situation
est un peu plus particulière ici à bali
puisque vous avez que le 26 il y aura la
fête de lippi qui est une fête
religieuse hindouistes qui certes vise
le confinement et le fait de rester chez
soi de ne pas utiliser d'électricité
pour obtenir la bénédiction des dieux
selon leurs croyances
il n'en demeure pas moins que cette fête
est précédé de nombreux rassemblements
et de suivi d'autant de rassemblement
aussi il est très facile de devenir très
inquiet ici par rapport à ce que la
situation va donner mal gré mal gré des
préconisations forte du gouvernement
indonésien
merci beaucoup razzy hammadi d'avoir a
été avec nous
je rappelle vous êtes actuellement à
bloquer du côté de bali en indonésie
merci et bon courage pour la suite